Lee is a former British soldier he did
two tours of duty in Northern Ireland
when you leave the army or the conflict
ends there is no process of step down so
in effect you have to leave those
veterans in a place where they're still
in conflict Michael is a former IRA
prisoner he was convicted of murdering a
police officer 25,000 of us have been
through the presents for her actions
against the British did during the
conflict a face-to-face meeting would
have been unthinkable before piece
together they talked about the troubles
right side an old army barracks in West
Belfast
so this would have been the
responsibility of a of a company from a
two-year battalion yeah I'm learning
every time a total of 300,000 soldiers
were sent to Northern Ireland 1,400 were
killed here operation banner was the
longest continuous deployment for
British troops but Lee and Michael agree
that veterans alone cannot be granted
immunity from historical prosecutions
they know by calling for an amnesty for
British soldiers it becomes a de facto
amnesty for all if they're calling for
an amnesty be honest about what that
really means and that means an amnesty
for British soldiers means an amnesty
for all I would rather have and their
permission retrieval process where
families Confederate information was
searched taken and you hear that what
most families are wanting the nor was
the why the British Army's welcome was
short-lived events like Bloody Sunday
when the parachute regiment shot 13
civilians dead in Londonderry swelled
the ranks of the IRA but the passage of
time has forged unlikely partnerships in
the pursuit of truth we don't know these
people as human beings we only hear them
as uniforms but the gallery can say come
to terms with the past and maybe be
Bolton as whatever you can at our low
level for the future as I moved further
away from the events I was able to look
at them from a more detached viewpoint
and I suddenly realized that the
black-and-white picture I'd be
given I needed to find the nuanced
mechanisms for addressing the legacy of
the past were paid out for public
consultation a clear majority opposed an
amnesty of any kind the victims on both
sides are simply not prepared to
sacrifice their right to pursue justice
the past is never far from the present
here but this conversation could not be
further from the violence once witnessed
on these streets
David Blevins Sky News in Belfast